and and I think I think most people
agree with an evidence-based look at the
world I don't know if they do
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance and kitten
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of watching people argue on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts are
brilliant guests this week is one of our
favorite comedians here in the UK Finn
Taylor low to trigonometry thank you
very mu make you feel guilty for being
pink why I'm not sure how useful this is
you know I think you mean you shouldn't
feel proud about being white I don't
need to tell Australia that I think it's
a healthy middle ground between the two
you know like I have an african-american
friend and he came over to London I was
shown him round and we ended up watching
this blues band right and the blues band
has five British white guys and he kicks
off in two oh this is [ __ ] it's
cultural appropriation and I'm like what
do you mean he's like well his blues
evolved out the songs that African
slaves would sing in the fields these
guys are white Umbridge they don't get
that [ __ ] it's culture appropriation
because blues is inherently a black art
form because of slavery and I was listen
to that thinking oh yeah maybe it's a
white British man you got to admit like
we had something to do with that as well
you didn't slave yourselves with a
concert idiot I mean it's like why
people have that equation you don't get
blues music dude it's important in it
cuz blues is the root of everything it
evolved into jazz which evolved into
gospel soul funk disco hip-hop rap you
can almost say [ __ ] either if it wasn't
for white people it's good to have you
here listen before anyone doesn't know
you who hasn't seen you perform
tell us a little bit about who you are
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life to the point
where you're sitting in this chair well
I'm a stand-up comedian had been for 10
years basically the only job I've ever
had I suppose in the last three years
I've started talking about identity
politics tribalism
lots of the same similar sort of things
that you talk about in this podcast and
it's since doing that I've had I guess a
relative level of success oh you've been
in live at the Apollo which is the
biggest comedy TV show in this country
at the moment I'll stand up yeah yeah
obviously it used to be on BBC one at 10
o'clock and now it's now some BBC two on
a Thursday yeah and you know get get I
get I do well available festival but I
do also managed to piss off a lot of
people by doing that
speaking of which which is really one of
the reasons we wanted to talk to you
this particular time is yeah you had an
article about you come out I think his
independent newspaper wasn't it yes
which is an online blog if you don't
know
yeah the independent comment section
which is open to all as became clear
when I read this they yeah they released
this article that it wasn't necessarily
about me but it opened with this person
who claimed to be a new comedian on the
circuit well the subject of the article
was as a comedian working the circuit I
am like something like horrified by
regret these old
progressive humor coming back into
comedy now there's lots of context I
mean it's been symptom Dean disproved
that he was actually a comedian lots of
lots of people on my behalf got in touch
with the independent that was way more
angry than I was about it like Stuart
Lee and Al Murray and Tom Rosenthal were
all emailing the independent trying to
see if he was real or Knox they thought
it might be like a spiked inside job but
it did sort of read like a spiked spoof
of a Guardian article but it turns out
this guy isn't a comedian but I at the
moment let's say he's real and the
article opens with him at my show my
recent show and just talk about gender
politics which I've seen yes no
compliment there just purely in facts I
have seen it so he walks out the show
after halfway through and in in the
article he says this is because it's
regressive Jim Davidson style he calls
it calls the show a thinly veiled rape
apology I totally disagree with there
was no yes I must just dress she was
obviously most people watching this
might have seen the show it's not what
the show is and what I think what I
think I do is I like to take subjects
that people feel very tense about and
are often divided into fairy facile kind
of infantile binaries and I like to just
explore them and investigate all areas
and angles and I don't try and land on a
specific side I you know I try and I I
sort of take all the arguments in good
faith I think there must be elements of
truth on both sides so the trying to
investigate a way of you know seeing
both these things so in this context it
was you know the me to thing which is
obviously is outpouring of rage about
how women haven't had a chance to have
their crimes that can be committed
against them properly processed how do
you balance that with the
ability of a hashtag ruining a man's
livelihood when it wasn't true now if
you those are but those are two problems
that coexist and it's childish to
pretend that one doesn't and so this is
often what gets you know if you say you
sort of get forced into a corner we have
to say I believe every everyone I
believe all women or you could say oh
it's all bollocks they're all lying and
obviously those are both ridicu know you
have to find a way of dealing with both
problems but if you you know what's
happened here is that I've sort of tried
to articulate quite a nuanced position
and and he said that just from deviating
from this this point of view I'm not
rape apologist and the irony is if he'd
stayed for the rest the show he would
have found out who the real rape
apologist Sinha commonly industry is as
that's who I sort of name in shame but I
probably can't go into that here as
you'll get done for libel but yeah it's
it was a strange article you then went
on to go and push this sort of thing
that is not quite often said nowadays
the you know these two camps in in
comedy comedies in the in the grips of
like a struggle for its soul and on one
side you have let's take of argument the
left who believe that comedy needs to
have a social conscience that as a
comedian you are sort of like an agent
actively participating at a culture your
words are powerful and you could end up
contributing to a culture of oppression
and the kind of totem pole the icon of
this side is people like Hannah Gadsby
who wrote this I mean arguably the most
successful Edinburgh show of ever sort
of a take down of comedy and from like a
you know a marginalized person's
perspective it's now on Netflix the of
the offices out of the argument is the
free speech is under threat this is just
comedy political correctness is killing
what's just you know meaningless jokes
and this article was placed from this
perspective pushing me into this camp
welcome i i i don't really think this
culture war exists in the way that a lot
of people like to believe it does i
think it's one that only really exists
online in this kind of endless ping-pong
match of [ __ ] block we gotta swear
yeah of course [ __ ] blogs and
preachers podcast man meaningless hot
takes but i as someone who you know
works the circuit solo shows arts
festivals i i don't really see these
battles taking place in an audience and
so i sort of that's why i didn't really
want to I was asked to reply to this
article in the independent tropics I was
like well no I'm gonna work for you for
free it's risking my reputation from you
but I didn't really want to play this
game that they push you into a corner
with you know you then accepting the
terms of their framing aren't you that
yeah there is these two battles and one
has to win and one is right and one is
wrong when I sort of think that you know
you can like different stuff hmm like me
and Hannah Gatsby have the same agent
yeah it's the same person is responsible
for both our careers in the UK I think
if this guy found that out his brain
would explode its life it's you know
it's I'd love to call it art but how how
is your cultural taste now inform by
your political values I don't see that
as at all true but do not think
sometimes I mean I've and I really like
your comedy I genuinely do but I've seen
a joke that you do on stage and in front
of a very liberal you know there is a
snowflake crowd and the moment you say
the joke you lose the you look you lost
them for a certain period of time and
you could see them tense up and shut
down and it was a joke aimed at
Mediterranean people my girlfriend is
greek cypriots you found it hilarious
yeah and all the middle-class white
people in the room thought
or hate monger well no do you know what
I'm saying well yeah I mean the point is
I do know when I'm losing the crowd yeah
that is deliberate because a lot of the
a lot of stuff is aimed at people like
me precious white liberals they're just
teasing how much they think about it
this is this is I suppose the thing is
that if I was doing these these jokes in
a you know if I was branded was branding
myself as you know free speech warrior
mmm this truth-teller then I would get a
crowd that want that you know people
that buy into that sort of side of the
argument but it's not fun as when it's
in front of a mixed crowd and that's
part of the reason I didn't want to sort
of get into this so much is that I'm
really proud of the fact that when I do
solo shows and the festivals and stuff
it's an insane mix of people that would
never normally be in the same room you
know you have you know there's old white
fellows in the three-piece suit the
fedora you know proper old Tories bear
sitting next to women with blue hair
you know polyamorous vegan queer
community people and they sort of
project their own things onto what I do
I think because I don't you know I
deliberately don't try and fit into one
of these worldviews that rubbishes the
other but yeah I'll tell your point III
know that I I actively do try and annoy
a lot of people but it's um you know
that Mediterranean joke the joke is in
the me to thing it's hard to know if
Harvard woman's know if a man is a sex
pest or he is just Mediterranean but
that's that's gained right it's just
about acceptable because it's a broad
enough group it's not really a
distinguished enough but then surely the
counter-argument to someone is that is
that you are being as a white male of
privilege yeah you were being
discriminatory to Mediterranean men you
know you're crossing them always being
you know particularly predatory that is
not fair that is not acceptable
neither is that right and I am offended
okay well it's a joke it's obviously not
true
the the untrue nurse of it should be
enough but there is a point of that I
suppose of the far-left who would
actually say well yet but you have a
duty and a responsibility yes but my
point is that it's a very small fringe
of people that actually think that and I
think the sort of the three speech guys
on the right are similarly I sort of
fringe on the right yeah yeah there's
also free speech people who are not on
the right of course I mean yes but there
are the people that push these I'm using
left and right justice in the people
that push these divides I just I don't
see I see 90% of comedy audiences do not
politicize their enjoyment or lack of it
if they find something funny they laugh
if they don't they don't they find it
edgy or close to the bow and they go oh
okay they enjoy making that noise yeah
yeah and if it's a bit woman's gonna go
there and if it's only a certain type of
person that walks into a show with a
kind of preset I think this well there's
a mutual friend of us who I'm not gonna
name on the show but he was doing a show
about men last year you may know how I'm
talking about and he was doing a preview
at a club that I know and and a woman
stood up in the middle of a show and
said you're a white man you're not
allowed to talk about this and wouldn't
leave until the show was ended
yeah that's my point that this person
would exist in that first I I as I see a
minority but that would not have
happened 10 years ago as my point no
maybe my number the minority has got
more emboldened on both sides and that's
possibly because both sides Oh way over
perceive the threat of the other hmm
because they have to because they're
reactive narratives you can't have the
we need to clean up comedy sort of you
know you guys are all dinosaurs without
the other guys saying were free speech
and you can't have they can't exist
without them because they're both
parasitic they live off the other right
and so they maybe got emboldened and
maybe got louder and maybe they have
more more spirit for a fight but I I
don't I just don't see it as something
that actually exists in the way
it's made up to so much online well
you've just described as exactly the
thing you're saying doesn't exist which
is the culture war that the two edges
becoming emboldened and then dragging
other people in that is the cultural
right it's it's it's there are small
minority that are sucking you in
yeah well they're sucking everybody in
because yeah our conversations in
society about privilege about
discrimination about you know something
we'll go on to talk about which is the
dude Acula another Pierre you've
actually been prosecuted for saying
things which were a joke like your
defense of your joke about mediterranean
people and i don't be offended by that
because i'm a quarter greek right yeah
your defense is that's a joke and it's
obviously not true but if you have
something like his case where the judge
said the prosecutor and the judge said
context doesn't matter intent doesn't
matter then you get into a point where
if you say something on stage and
someone chooses to take it literally and
you say a lot of stuff that can be
misinterpreted that way yes sure right
then you end up in a position where you
can be criminalized so I guess what I'm
saying is if you say there's no culture
well I think what you're saying is
there's no culture war in broader
society right in in them in the
mainstream of society which I can kind
of agree with to some extent yeah but I
feel the only reason that that's true is
that this way of thinking hasn't seeped
into that far into but it will because
yeah universities these people are being
indoctrinated so yeah so so you see it
as a precedent to a kind of dystopia
yeah
whenever I and sometimes I do but I'm
then I then go off Twitter for a week
and I and I just do gigs no you know
Friday Saturday night clubs and these
these hot takes don't exist people enjoy
it or they don't enjoy it in and you
know 16 percent of the UK are on Twitter
I mean just just think about how small
that's comedians media people
politicians journalists and [ __ ]
lunatics that is and it feels so much
louder when you're there you think this
is representative yeah but I don't it's
not
and I can I know that from experience
because as someone who you know talks
about these arguments that are made
online when I try and do jokes about
certain things people have no idea what
I'm talking about yeah like I tried to
do a bit in my last show and a whole bit
about a transgender movement and how
it's sort of competed with women's
rights and that's kind of aspect of the
argument again one that mainly takes
place online and I try to do a thing
about the term cisgender
and say you know oh this is what you're
happy this is a word for if you're born
a man and you're still a man which is
good I never knew what the word for that
was people don't know what that term is
like the people that come in so it's you
know and I really thought I was a funny
joke so I really kept trying to do it
but it just wouldn't fly because people
didn't know what the premise is yeah
and so I I do see these as sort of as
fringe mad discussions rather than
something that is is seeping in okay so
here's here's the point yeah five years
from now yeah you're going to be fine
during that joke maybe you are maybe
even this year if you'd go and tell him
bro this year you'd be fine doing that
joke because we're talking about you
know Piers Morgan has people talking
about trans on national TV like every
second day or whatever he's becoming a
much bigger part of the conversation so
this obsession with identity is
spreading it's not just static it's not
just there's that 3% of people who care
about on one side 3% on the other side
and it's staying there in my opinion is
spreading that we're talking about more
and more and it's not right now maybe
that's the 16% of people on Twitter but
it's spreading into mainstream society
maybe it is
I would guess and we won't know until
the future what was telling was that all
the responses to this article that was
basically framing this debate were like
shut up mate it's just comedy like
people didn't really have the a lot of
the responses to the article the guy at
the port I mean I feel sorry for me had
to like move his photo and Delftware
because he's getting so much hate which
I don't condone by the way and he like
most people don't have the sort of
vocabulary tough to meet these that was
what was no school and that they're not
participate
in the cultural because they don't
really know it was existed just like
just jokes shut up you know this is most
people's response I find he does feel
like a very insular navel-gazing comedy
media class thing and you could be right
I'm you know I don't know maybe it will
spread out to the broader but that's why
I mean that's why I'm concerned about
it's not because I think that right now
we live in an oppressive society where
no one can say what they guess but there
is a direction of travel well right and
yeah I would I I guess I disagree that
that that's inevitable or or it's moving
its I always find it funny when people
say this is this sets a precedent
because there's often a huge caveat to
that precedent like um recently there
was the you know Shamima begum case
where she was stripped of assistantship
the ISIS bride and it's a fair point a
lot of people from second generation
immigrants were on Newsnight saying this
sets a dangerous precedent because could
I just have my citizenship revoked and
the caveat is well do you want to join
Isis any consequences like that's a
massive part of the context of that but
I you know so I sort of think when
people say it sets a precedent I'm I
don't know it never it never seems to
get very I'm sure it's where the real
actually yeah its signals are coming to
stop you or whether it's just a loud
fringe order a couple of points I want
to make number one I think you're
Mediterranean undeniable as somebody who
is in a long-term relationship with a
Mediterranean woman and her family
nailed it number one and number two I
take your point about you saying the the
the common person isn't interested in it
and the reason is is because you know
being a former teacher most people are
so wrapped up in their own lives and you
know whether they've you know they've
got family they've got kids they've got
a job they've got to hold down they've
got to do the school and everything else
that these sort of wars that go on
online they just don't appear in the
public consciousness simply because
people don't have the time however I
think the real danger is is the people
who dictate what it is that we consume
in mainstream media are very much part
of that particular ideology and war and
that's where I think it might seep in
so what you're going to get is comedy
becoming more and more sanitized as it
were and certain points of view not
being represented like if you think
about it the majority of people in this
country in the referendum voted brexit
whether you agree whether you disagree
but Jeff Northcott is really the only
pro brexit comedian on mainstream media
yeah I mean I suppose that's true well
firstly when you said that you think
commies didn't get more sanitized yeah
it's in the a more sanitized perhaps on
the BBC ya Netflix it's gonna piss the
opposite right and the BBC I already
know are trying to catch up so I'm not
sure it will be sanitized but maybe
you're you're correct in that and maybe
this is where you might have a point
is that people are increasingly comics
are increasingly branding themselves
they're taking aside on these on these
little binary debates and they can sell
a lot of tickets that way I suppose in
the I'm is something I'm reluctant to do
I don't I don't disrespect anyone for
doing it but it's something I'm
reluctant to do in that I I really like
that my audience is mixed and I like
that they come because I sort of take
the piss up every side of a of a debate
III would be I would be kind of reticent
to brand myself as one or the other
because then you'd get people coming but
they're coming because they they think
that you think the same as them mmm and
I don't think that's that's for me it's
not as fun I like having bit of spice in
there in the gig in Toronto you know
toss ideas around in the knowledge that
they might all be wrong they might all
be right you don't know and it's also
more authentic as well because nobody's
wholly on the right nobody's wholly on
the Left that we were talking to Peter
Hitchens
I think he'll Peter would describe
himself as being more towards oh right
of the political will is this social
conservative yeah I guess economically
Democrats yes and absolutely and he's in
favor of the nationalization the
railways which is actually a left-wing
policy well that I think most most
people are evidence-based well no
like I'm the I am a huge I was so
excited when the independent group broke
away from raping the toys so excited and
I don't think there's any any
coincidence that they're all a lot of
them are former barristers because they
they want that evidence-based approach
to policy which is something that we
just sort of been have been abandoned by
the two major parties right both are
sticking to fanatical dogma and and I
think I think most people agree with an
evidence-based look at the world I don't
know if they do my people should I feel
it feels like maybe there was a time
when people did maybe after the Cold War
with me sort of everyone cooled down a
bit and said yeah these these dogmatic
ways of of looking at the world don't
work but then that was a very brief
window wasn't it feels like we're back
there hey sorry Karen I was gonna say
we're coming back to comedy one of the
things that Francis and I often talk
about is because we're digging comedians
like you are is like Francis might write
a great bit and then which I know is
funny you know there's a comedian you
kind of know sometimes what's funny on
what isn't and there are certain clubs
where he can't do that bit you know well
I have routines that two years ago were
hilarious and now everyone just goes boo
so have you seen a change in the ten
years that you've been a comedian in
terms of what people find edgy what
would the definition of edgy has changed
I don't know because I wasn't really
it's only been in about the last three
or four years and I suppose I've been
reviewed as provocative as I was given
property of AG I don't know I mean when
you say there are some clubs you can't
do certain jokes at I never found that
oh really I yeah I which is why I think
the you know I I know you so you had a
thing where you were told you couldn't
you have this contract to agree with it
was a Goldsmith's or so right it's one
of those two things basically the two
and that's obviously just I see that as
just you know silly students righteous
indignation that is a phase that they
were I won't last like every generation
will think that for a bit
I
thing like that then I got older read
more similarly I you know that this is a
free speech gig isn't there I know you
guys have done yeah yeah
comedy Unleashed yeah right the reason
there's nothing that I would do at that
gig that I wouldn't do it any other show
yeah
now I don't know whether that's because
I have a broken radar but I I just I've
always just done whatever I wanted to do
and as I I don't really see that the
comics being censored thing other but do
you not think there are certain times
and maybe there are certain routines
that I like I used to talk about my mom
being a trump supporter yeah which she
is she's a disabled latin-american 73u a
woman who supports Donald Trump right
and which is funny
yeah and I've done it onstage at gigs
and people just shut down just like that
they hear the word Donald Trump about
you've been booed I mean I was booed at
up the creek which everyone has been but
yeah I mean what I mean the punch line
is but then I understand why people vote
for Donald Trump because it's very
difficult nowadays to be a nice kind
tolerant person well we live in a world
where estate agents exist right right ok
because every time I see a group of
estate agents in my area I behave a
little bit like a racist I'll see them I
think yeah it's too many of them around
here yeah they look the [ __ ] same to
me
I'll go look guys chill out I'm not
prejudiced uh some of my best friends
are estate agents I just want one marry
my daughter because one's if they had a
kid it would come out half normal of a
state agent and we know what we call one
of them don't we a recruitment
consultant bang yeah but I've just lost
them and before that you said two years
ago or a year even a year and a half ago
that used to be one of the biggest bits
in the set and the recruitment
consultant ban because it's something
silly to bookend what is a sort of
serious political point but at the
moment I've found that I do that trumpet
they just got oh and then yeah or maybe
I just don't have the skill yet to be
able to take that and just get people to
go with it well
I've not found I I don't find maybe but
maybe people you there are some giggle
people are more yeah clenchy yeah but
then I was from performing in a way
where I know that they're uncomfortable
and that I'm in control of that yeah you
know a lot of my eye contact is like
this is going go on beat heads coming
which I guess is sort of signaling your
intent
maybe there's a performance trick
because um that's one of the things
about irony is that I think quite often
people mistake irony for saying
something horrible and then someone
calls you out and then you go I know I
was when really you know you have to you
have to perform you have to show people
that you don't mean what you say yeah
via other means yeah so there is some
responsibility to how you say these
things
yeah I think but look I'm not denying
that you've had that experience but I I
don't I don't see that except your lived
experience experience but yeah so I
don't feel them you know the only time
any of my friends have had stuff like
this is people when Nicias of course the
riot because he's just so empty breaks
it I love them Saturday unplugged is
microphone really yeah yeah but then you
know he's he's he's going for he's he's
deliberately stoking a bit of lease
token but you know he's on one side yeah
he's doing stuff that's lifting the
other side and you know Saturday night
they're going to be lead it's amazing
people don't realize that breaks it will
divide a rug
well it's divided a country's exactly
but maybe that's because you know my
stuff is about these subjects but
doesn't doesn't take aside people feel
that they can laugh at it because I
don't feel they're under attack yes some
people obviously some people just just
hear that you're not parroting their
their point of view and you write
articles in the independent so yes oh no
no there's no it's it's it's an
interesting point that you make and you
know maybe yeah I don't see I don't see
it yeah I don't I don't feel
censored I don't feel like comic sir
under threat when I did live with Apollo
I went into the the bar afterwards and
the head of BBC two told me you know
whatever happens we have to we always
have to have a space for this type of
comedy on the channel that's the head of
the BBC the head of the channel saying
that yeah
is that why why Frankie Boyle and Jimmy
Carr not being canceled it's because
they don't wade into these debates in
the way that Ricky Gervais does yeah and
I think that's quite sage actually I
think that's because they've realised
that they're trying to play too you know
loads of people and even though they
might be talking about these sort of
topics and doing quite brutal jokes
they're not taking a side they're not
dismissing one side of the other yeah
that's how I see it anyway
well the thing that strikes me whenever
you and I have talked about this is like
your angle sometimes seems to be like
well I don't feel censored and the you
know free speech isn't about you know
it's about a principle and it's about
other people like it's like the benefit
system you don't stand up for the
benefit system because you want benefits
you know you stand up for it because
there's people yes
[Music]
speaking of scars people let's talk
about thank Allah yes
that was irony by the way the first
caller shoes I'm half Scottish is ie
yes yeah oh you name is Finley so that
was one of the you said you watched our
interview with him
yeah which has you know loads of people
have commented they've watched it it was
an interesting case you said on the
phone when we talked there were certain
things you didn't agree with us about or
you well I am wasn't so much that so I
didn't really have an opinion on it when
you asked me about it and then I I
watched because I thought if I had to
have many pay attention to the case I
watched the interview I didn't watch the
video in question and I sort of see why
he got into trouble and that's not me
saying that he should gone to jail but I
mean I think it's right quite press I'm
quite telling that he hasn't I'm sure he
will but I mean this is this is one of
the weakest hot takes of all time but
the Internet has changed everything so
if when you do comedy for a channel
there is a team of lawyers that are
attached to that channel that kept there
year-round on retainer and their job is
to make sure that every joke every
premise every sketch whatever the show
is is defensible because we have these
laws around broadcasting in society that
we also an up to that some things are
shouldn't be broadcast before certain
time because of children some things are
you know bad taste or whatever and so we
have these standards when it's a
publicly owned channel might have ABC
and other another you know free view
channels that that's that's the you know
that's the lay of the land now one of
the great things about the Internet is
that there's no gatekeepers any void
enough to wait for someone to put you on
a channel you can just upload stuff
straight to the Internet and and if it
gets shared enough more people will ever
will see it and will ever see you doing
something late-night on BBC 2 however
there is no machinery there to uphold
the same principles of you know
maintaining the social fabric you know
it's just unfiltered it's straight it's
direct
many times that's a good thing but how
do you stop someone from just pumping
hate speech into the ether well done
what are you doing hey let me escape
yeah okay
because when free speeches is is
defended it's also the argument well
there's a context context is everything
but I always find that the context is
always just sure of like further context
it's always a convenient amount of
context because I think you both agreed
we have there's a huge problem with hey
abuse online yeah the magnet yeah it's
you know young young teenage girls are
killing themselves because of things
they're seeing today as we record this
there's been a there's been a mass
shooting in New Zealand and people it
was being broadcast live on YouTube and
all it said was this might be an
appropriate click to proceed right
that's the only so it is totally
unregulated the the big tech companies
they're all you know whacking off to
Iran books they're not going to regulate
anything there's kind of these ultra
libertarian ideologues and so there is
going to be this conflict over the next
10 years between state and Internet how
do you protect people from the darker
side of the internet I think that's a
contest that's going to happen and that
should that's my opinion what I see the
countdown killer thing as is a sort of
growing pain in that initial thing in
that it's ridiculous that it's clearly
he says it's a joke it's context to a
joke but at the same time he says the
phrase gas the Jews however many 40
times and for a lot of that the park
isn't really doing anything and I'm not
saying as you go to jail but I sort of
see this as maybe a misstep
maybe maybe heavy-handedness but I see
it as an initial foray in trying to deal
with this conflict between state
responsibility and an unregulated online
space and I can't help but feel if if
count Anki law was a Muslim comic and
was that pug was watching videos of
jihad ease beheading journalists and
9/11 footage in like
clapping stuff which might be funny I
can't help but feel that the same people
defending him would be crowing for him
to be banged up why because there is a
context of Muslim men getting
radicalized online and that has to be
dealt with right so this is what I see
there is definitely gonna be a conflict
but I see it is there something that
sort of needs needs to happen I think
what I said my opinion o this what make
him feel any better and also a large
part this comes in fact is a YouTube
comedian and will get way more viewers
than I ever will doing a proper comedian
but I think what the state seems to have
done is gone right you find a hundred
pounds you welcome take you to jail
which is really exciting to go to jail
for but justice or the needs to be seen
they send on the letter saying they will
take him to jail right of that interview
okay
well maybe he will go to jail I I feel
like they said well there's several
cases of people being like you convicted
dude we're not gonna go to jail they try
and make the whole thing disappear
quietly because they sort of realizes a
bit ridiculous
mm-hmm so that's how I see it which I
know is a nuanced point but it's really
vital that we have these discussions and
I think because going back to the
polarization the internet the internet
is where these conversations appear to
take place in a public forum and a lot
of the time it just seems to be two
sides screaming each other that we've
nobody really listening or sharing a
point you've just made a point and it
enabled me to reflect and I'll go away
ruminate and change my point my my point
will develop the one thing that I'll
leave to you but the one thing that I
found worrying was it was it was the
judge saying that context isn't
important and I found that particularly
dangerous as comedians at foot for
everyone because we can't anybody's set
you can take something out out of
context yeah sure that that's probably
most worrying bit is not the actual
conviction it's the judge saying context
doesn't matter but at the same time name
name me a comedian that's in jail in
this country name me someone that has
had their free speech seriously
threatened removed this is this is I
think where the difference is is you're
talking about the present your focus is
in all of these instances on the present
mm-hmm
and I think what I don't know where the
Frances is but what I'm talking about is
a direction of travel
right because thank Allah is not the
only person there lots of other people
there's Chelsey Russell yes who have
been called by the police to check their
internal chassis Russell was arrested
prosecuted tagged and she only recently
won an appeal right right episode she
she had a life room for two years
because she shared some lyrics from a
rap song online as a tribute to a friend
of hers who had died who loved those
lyrics right and they contain downward
and she's white and she's white right
right so she was prosecuted for this
tagged her life was ruined by this yeah
right police are calling as you said you
know people who retweeted some kind of
supposedly transphobic Limerick and
telling them that they need to check
they're thinking yeah right
which is that you you you're right I
guess as someone who grew up in Soviet
Union you're more sensitive to this
source stuff yeah and rightly so that
you say this stuff and it sounds it
sounds scary but again I see it as a
sort of necessary struggle in between
the state regulating the online space
which I think you have to agree
something has to be they need to be
curricular you know basically every
woman in public life is constantly every
day being told they're going to be raped
or killed I get tons of hate online as
well yes we all do deserve we all do and
but when he actually when it does you
know when people are broadcasting mass
shootings yeah surely there has to be
something to you know something about I
just don't see the connection between
Daniel and mass shootings these are
separate issues to me right well because
he was he was he was prosecuted for
being grossly offensive public indecency
essentially right gross defensive online
yeah that is the state trying to trying
to clean up the online space yeah which
he needs to do because at the moment
it's unregulated that mass shootings are
broadcast that that's the context of the
the online
sphere that's how I see it right and the
thing about you know free speech is it
an absolute is it not is it I think free
speech yes for all but also the
responsibility should be taken by
everyone with it you know like the Boris
Johnson thing when he was um
you made that comment about Muslim women
looking like letterboxes and everyone
pilloried him and then everyone defended
him by saying why free countries free
speech he's a colorful character and my
reading of it is that we'll look I'm a
comedian I can say Muslim women look
like letterboxes because I'm a comedian
and the privileges you can say anything
however there's a curse you cannot
really ever be taken seriously because
you're a comedian Boris Johnson is a
politician he is privileged in that he
is taken seriously because he represents
people I mean on a contextual level yeah
cassette role of a rather Boris Johnson
has a privilege that people you know he
can be taken seriously represents people
the curses he can't say whatever he
wants
like he just said you don't have impede
on this show because they can't actually
say what they that is the kind of the
gift and the curse yeah of being in you
know democratic politician in the same
way that a comedian has the sort of vice
versa you know and maybe this
distinction has been muddied by the
proliferation of comedians you know
being taken seriously as news hosts and
sort of satirical and appearing on
question time yeah I remember I had a
conversation with the question time
producers and I just was like I just
don't think I should do it because
unless I just took the whole thing down
yeah because I don't
again you'll then branding yourself as
you know I think this come see me
because you think this and that's just
not something I wanted I want to I want
to do but yeah there is there is this
maybe people have started getting their
news more from comedians and I think it
strokes comedians ego to be taken
seriously but then it then maybe it
muddies the distinction in that some
people who who go to comedians and you
know listen to their routines as if
they're you know political activism they
then would look at what I do and go well
you so this is our yeah but I'm off I'm
not trying I'm not attempting to be
taking anywhere near as seriously at
this guy yeah so maybe that's why well I
mean in terms of the news I think the
Daily Show particularly after Jon
Stewart left it's become an ideological
kind of this and what we think
in a way that I don't think it was
before we'll look at the mass report
right somebody's been on it oh yeah I
would defend it but yeah well no I'm not
I'm not saying it there's anything wrong
with it I'm saying it's a it's something
that reflects a particular way of
thinking right and it's comedy which
presents that way of thinking through
comedy that more people probably will
watch them watch more most of the news
the same with the Daily Show so I know
loads of people now like when this whole
free speech thing happened with me or
this whole contract thing happened with
me I I did a show in America called the
Tucker Carlson show which is on Fox News
you see the guy who's recently yeah yeah
yeah I didn't watch the video I just saw
him is being canceled on my yeah yeah
exactly exactly right so anyway I was
talking to a comedian and he said what
was it like being on that show cuz I
must have been like really weird
and I was like how do you mean and he
was like well you just like really
right-wing isn't he and I was like well
have you seen this show do you watch a
show cuz I'm not saying he's not
right-wing I'm just saying have you seen
the show cuz I'm curious where you're
coming from and goes oh no I haven't
seen a show but I've just seen what the
Daily The Daily Show says about him
right so people get their opinions now
through these comedy shows yeah yeah I
guess what feeds very much into what
you're saying
well it might it might be part of the
reason why you know that bloke wrote
that article about me is because he's
watched comedians and seen them as
political pundits because some comedians
it's a stroke your ego to be taken
seriously because the reason we're
comedians that no one ever takes us
seriously and someone asked you for your
opinion go oh yeah you know I was sort
of raised about doing this because I'm
you know for this hour I'm not who I am
on stage I'm just you know so um yeah it
kind of muddies the waters suddenly
people are like ah he makes a really
good point so when you see a comedian
that's that's talking about this stuff
but is you know it's just being stupid
and you know not taking a sigh is just
presenting these arguments then maybe
you take it as seriously as you do the
you know the the left-wing satirist or
whatever and maybe that's why the waters
get muddy but there are certain
comedians do have a lot of power if you
think about someone like Bill Hicks I
mean there's a George Carlin George
Carlin there you know
but they mobilized a lot of people who
ended up espousing their views and maybe
you you're right they do grow out of it
and all the rest of it well I Bill Hicks
has a whole range of Bill Hicks has
quite intelligent people wondering about
the power of the state and people who
think the [ __ ] did 9/11 who like Bill
Hicks you can't you can't say that they
all you know people have different views
and they like people because they
project what they think onto them I
think to a certain amount George
Carlin's a free thinker right yeah he
some things Ferry
you know socialist some some things he
says a nowadays would be seeing as it's
quite sort of reactionary anti PC I
suppose there's no political correctness
is pretending to be manners yes but then
also there's he was a was he immersive I
can't member if he was socialist
economic anyway because it doesn't
matter but we're just gonna let it pause
there you see this is why 1970s chat
shows were great because when people did
they were small we're smoking so you
just did it and it just look really
atmospheric you take your time have a
draw put it back this is drug King on
camera drinking on camera you got the
smoke effect in front the little male
health and safety is ruined it all
[ __ ] political correctness and this
is what we're [ __ ] to yeah what I was
going to say is that yep I got reviewed
as being free thinking and I like that
yeah because that reflects the audience
yeah yeah isn't these people from you
know you look out at the I look I did
some theater last month and you look out
one of the Nights and it feels like it
feels like the venues for a live event
from the spectator and vice I've got
mixed up yeah it's just all kinds of
crazy and I really like that but I
suppose that does run the risk of very
dogmatic people on either side not
enjoying it yeah and you know one of the
few TV things i've done i've had i have
pissed off the extremes of both these
sides i think is the right way to do it
you know piss everyone off at the same
time
and I suppose what I do what I have
found that today which may be played
into the narrative that I know you guys
like there is a there is there is
something of of people getting offended
on behalf of people loath to call it
virtue signals it's such a cliche now
but I did on Apollo I did stuff about my
routine about trans rights and got a
couple of really nice emails and tweets
from transgender charities that said
well normally we complain whenever
anyone makes a joke about trans rights
but we just want to say we found it
really funny indeed on your research I
was like great yeah I thought I had I
made sure I read loads of books about
the arguments and books by trans women
and stuff and but on Twitter there's
loads of people who weren't transgender
standing up for transgender thanking me
as sort of a transphobic Bernhard
manning and it's fascinating because
it's almost like if you if people feel
like if people assume that if you're
talking about these things
it must be derogatory it must be but
exactly yeah but this is so this the
Rutina is is it's I think Trent you
should let trans women piss where they
one yeah ultimately and I sort of you
know a Bunkley idea that maybe there's
going to allow sex press into the
bathrooms but ultimately because you
think about it these fellows are taking
a pay cut yeah now that is a progressive
joke on several levels because what I'm
saying is if you let these trans women
into women's spaces because you know in
good faith because when you transition
you lose a certain amount of male
privilege yeah and then you're
acknowledging the existence of a wage
gap yeah now what's the funniest way of
saying that these fellows taking a pay
cut yeah girl always you're just you're
just parroting so it's a very
progressive joke yeah but because you
know you're handling the subject people
seem to yeah the point this is exactly
the point look I have a bit about me
being called a [ __ ] which is absolutely
true Yeah right
a lot of apologize and it's always Asian
people that laugh at that joke and it's
always white middle-class people that
turns up about that right right like you
you and I both have you have a routine
about you know always cheering for the
white guy and 100 meter final yeah I
have a routine about how we need a
Special Olympics for white people right
it's always the ethnic minorities who
laugh at that bit
it's always the white middle-class
liberal people who turns up about that
but what yeah but what's your point
about how this leads into my speech so
it's on my point no it's not about free
speech my point is that when people get
offended on behalf of other people which
is what you're saying yeah right if this
idea that we should all be super
sensitive and super offended on behalf
of other people spreads right and it's
spreading from universities this is
where it's happening it's not just that
young people go through this phase it's
not by accident
can I just I I hear that argument a lot
and I think we'll never get said is that
everyone is a dick at University and
grows out of it and not everyone no no
everyone but it's often to these ideas
or indoctrinated students yes spreading
out but what it what it implies is that
students stay the same age and have no
life but when it sort of does in that
it's saying that everyone I'm agreeing
with I'm saying no they don't stay the
time yet so um yeah it's it's implying
that students say the same agent and
carry that with them
you don't live a life and move away from
the curve dogmatic views that helps a
student which is what I think will
happen in the majority which is part of
the reason majority yes who's the most
influential democratic politician in
America right now beta O'Rourke no
Alexandra has a quarter oh yeah her
right yeah that's her that's her in a
nutshell
she is someone who's from that mindset
is 29 years old straight into being a
congresswoman Yeah right so what's going
to happen over time is that the people
who come out of university if they're
not challenged this is the point about
you talking about online and hate speech
and how do I agree with you that's a
really good point I thought and I
thought the way you laid that out the
fact that we have to deal with tank
Euler there's a struggle yeah over
constrain yeah yeah I think that's a
very good point and I think we sometimes
get into a partisanship about that
that's not helpful
but I think that what what's happening
with universities is
reason that we have to push back against
things like thank you loose in my
opinion right don't tell me what you
think is that if that is a struggle then
people who are like us on the side of
expression right have to put up our end
of the fight we have to say this is
where the line is right thank Allah was
too far right because you say you
understand why he got into trouble but
you don't approve of him being convicted
yes but I suppose what these culture
what these what these binaries make you
do is they make you turn someone into
like a martyr or a kind of icon yeah I
personally think count dangler should be
buried like bin Laden no but like that's
what it's why I'm loath to kind of
defend him because as I'm sure you'll
agree the free speech argument can get
hijacked by people who just want to be
racist no no sure but that's why I think
you have to be more measured in how you
see these things and I do think whether
it's the safe space you know control
speech thing or the free speech they I
do think you sort of have to choose to
think that that way yeah sorry I mean I
don't understand I don't follow the
logic of what you're saying we have to
be careful about defending free speech
because some people will hijack it who a
racist
agreed yeah well how is that relevant
and angular in that the reason that I
don't feel like put you know struggling
for countdown kill yeah is because I
don't I feel like this is someone who
what he's doing I don't I don't feel
particularly strongly about whether he
didn't I'm not sure whether he made an
everyone not there's maybe it's the
point is that I'm not I used to watch
the video and I don't I don't know if
it's if its intent is clear enough do
you think he was doing and I'm just
saying okay he says Gossage is 50 times
yeah context is I'm joking it's a dog
yes I'm a Chelsea fan right have been
for years
dad's always taken me as a kid this
seasons we record this there's been a
lot of attempts by the club to clean up
anti-semitic chanting a way game loss
Chelsea fans held banners SS death
squads gas chime chambers all this [ __ ]
because there's a rivalry of Tottenham
yeah living into a show of London now
I've stood in the stands while people
shout songs that have the word Yid in
them and you know just a horrible
antigen needless anti-semitic chanting
and you know thankfully the stat people
are shouting them down in the stands but
the argument they say is always the same
George is banter she's been football
banter hmm but you know Raheem Sterling
was abused usually as a by Chelsea fan
in the grounds yeah so what where is the
where's the line where is the line in
like the context of a being just banter
a football game but the thing so the
thing that with to me with Chelsea it's
obvious the intent is to hurt people but
oh but they would say they would say
Elba know is did we just rivalry it's a
club rivalry yeah and this is my point
is that it's at some point the line is
going to get so fuzzy that I I genuinely
just I don't know and I understand the
argument that we have to defend him even
if we don't like him that's what free
speech is but at the same time I'm
someone who believes that you know the
public space has to be a bit cleaner
online and so there's gonna be things
that are right to the edge and I jus
I'm interested I'm more interested to
see how it plays out and maybe the
reappointing that someone crosses that
line and I'm like [ __ ] this this is this
is my business my lab it yeah oh yeah
art if you can call it that yeah but you
know somebody goes to Chelsea games and
sees sort of front line of this kind of
stuff in it and it's wrapped up in this
oh it's harmless Club banter we're
supporting the same team so um I guess
my point is that it's very nuanced and I
would like to emphasize that it's
nuanced and in order to do that I don't
feel like I could people will just take
your support as
you're white all that side of it yeah
and that that I guess you know that's
part of the reason I didn't want to
write reply to the independent ones
comment yeah I want to try and
articulate this huge middle ground that
is so often unreported that most people
think in these kind of middle ground
yeah and all these debates that happen
online it's either you believe in free
speech or free speech equals racism yeah
and my point is I'm not going to say the
buzzwords on either side because I
believe this is a struggle that is
playing out that's that's you know that
point very well yeah and it's great and
it's it's really really lovely to hear a
different point of view as well well
thank you for that it's a very useful
conversation I think and I think it's
having these conversations that allows
us to find where that line is
yeah i yeah it's interesting with Dan
Keeler in there we will wrap up shortly
and that part of it I feel that people
came down on him because immediately it
wasn't skillful if he'd actually edited
it and done it a little bit more
differently and you know framed it a
little bit differently and look there I
said a little less working-class maybe
yeah it wouldn't because it's fine for
Jimmy Carter go on stage and make jokes
about gypsies
but the smelling badly while stressed in
a suit with a posh accent but this is
well this it but this is all part of
being a comedian yeah it's your front of
a live audience yeah and your sort of
your your your manner your context is
policed by that social interaction yeah
like when you're reading a book you ever
read a book that's like like American
Psycho so yeah like the liter and you're
gonna tube like Jesus Christ but it's a
book right it's just you your head when
you're in a comedy audience it's kind of
policed by everyone else laughing
there's a context yeah it's all sort of
safe really and I suppose that's maybe
one of the reasons why Thank You Lou had
you know it was straight to the Internet
yeah which is a place of genuine
anti-semitic hate yeah incitement and
and so maybe that's where these uh peace
things fall down maybe if he was someone
that did more live comedy he would
understand the kind of or maybe he would
be more intuitive his sort of sense of
yeah and this also as well I do think
that class plays a part to it because
when you see Jimmy Carr there are
certain jokes that he's done
Gipsy's being a prime example we go
would you have got away with that if you
looked and sounded like Marcus I'm not
sure absolutely
but there we go I think that might be
mr. man thanks for coming in thank you
as I said I think it's very useful that
you've articulated that Center ground
maybe made me think quite a bit actually
in terms of what I think I do think that
within the context of what you're saying
if there is that struggle to define the
appropriate level of unsafe nough slet
say that you have then they've got to be
people like us who go okay well we hear
what you're saying
right yeah but there's certain lines we
don't cross and maybe that's true but
it's what's also true is that that that
position is now tainted in the binary
yeah isn't it yes that's exactly the
position of saying well we have to
defend this guy yeah is now is tainted
so you know I can't you know you're
saying that doesn't help yeah so that's
why I'm loathe to do yeah you've closed
to defending me the way you do because I
actually want people to move past these
these just endless you know yeah yeah
so yeah yeah it's good it's good to have
you listen last question we always ask
is what's the one thing no one's talking
about the will to be talking about
please don't make it bad Mediterranean
people somewhere my girlfriend is
clapping her hands okay he also Soros
instinct has come out there you know
what's the one people that think people
are talking about they shouldn't be
talking let's say let's say let's say
automation and I guess feed into that
idea of regulating whether you regulate
the internet or not our our relationship
with machines whether it be you know how
is it going to change capitalism housing
change like work life how we going to
make algorithms ethical or this stuff
it's been completely ignored by both
major parties most most online
commentators you know how do you make
communities feel vital when everything
is done you know remotely all that stuff
is no way it's probably tied into breaks
it as it as an underlying cause of it
but it's not it's just been lost in this
endless head-banging over whether we
should be in the EU or not yes so yeah
let me say that automation it's
fascinating point that automation thing
in the algorithms especially because I
remember there's a Israeli historian
called you all know her oh yeah he talks
about this and he was saying that like
the door automated cars of the future
someone somewhere is gonna have to make
a decision if you can kill a pedestrian
or crash into another car yeah you know
someone's gonna have to sit down and go
I think we should kill the pedestrian
who's that person right you see the
ethical anyway thanks for coming on your
Twitter is at Finn Tyler Clementi Taylor
you're off to Mel bond very shortly yes
there all of April and then I've got one
last show the the the infamous rape
apology ISM which is on it the thing is
the 3rd of May at the South Bank in
London and the show is called when her a
see Met Sally so follow Finn on Twitter
check amazed is one of my absolutely
favorite comedians even though he's
completely wrong I've always been a big
fan of yours Thank You Finn is really
really good we might even put a little
clip of Finn's comedy in yeah yeah
absolutely bit me of me saying that yes
and we've got we've got quite a few was
he followers and viewers so go and see
Finn he's brilliant and my girlfriend
genuinely really likes that
Mediterranean show and in fact she's
insisted that we go and watch your show
British sushi can legs be exposed to
more hate speech right and on that no
thank you very much guys Constantine do
you want to do the outro absolutely or
as always follow us at trigger pod on
twitter facebook instagram subscribe to
the youtube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button and we
will see you in a week from now with
another brilliant episode absolutely oh
and one more thing guys if you think
you've subscribed YouTube has a nasty
little habit of unsubscribing you please
make sure please check
and if it has reclip the bell button and
all the rest of it and we'll see you
next week
bye-bye
[Music]